Now, I, I'm not familiar with ultra
footwear, but what I wanted to ask you is,
does anybody wear like minimalist
shoes and run these ultra marathons?
Yeah, yeah. There was, uh,
there was actually a Gal,
I cannot remember her name,
this is a couple of years ago who ran
ultra is in um, those Vibram FiveFingers.
Really? Yeah, yeah. In a trail
stuff too. So, um, you know,
it must have been a beast.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It was hard to run just
a couple of miles and it's, you know,
it's interesting because so ultra footwear
made the shoe this last year called
uh, the, the vanish and it's
essentially a minimalist shoe.
I'm just like a little bit of fabric on
the top, super, super hard flat base.
And that's kind of what I like
when I'm on a road or a track. Um,
so I was wearing that,
the vanish vanish. Yeah.
Pull that up and see what that looks
like. And it's a, so I went to this, this,
this ultra race and I wore those thinking
I'm going to have the lightest shoe
out of anyone here. Three guys show
up running completely barefoot.
Why they ran an ultra marathons barefoot?
Yeah, he had to. That's another level.
There was one,
there was one guy who is Christ,
he's like a to 22 or 23
marathoner and he's barefoot.
And he said that he runs a marathon bear,
so he doesn't do the marathon barefoot.
He actually said that, uh, the,
that's a little bit of padding
in that it looks like we're less,
there's a lip on the outside.
Is that the vanish or is
that the s is that it says
vantage guy. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So I mean there's, there's a
little bit, there's like a,
there's like a carbon fiber plate and you
see where that little cut is in there.
There's like a carbon fiber plate in
there that makes it a little more firm.
So when I'm looking for in a shoe and
I'm looking for kind of like that natural
feel is something that's got a affirm
its soul or affirm durometer because like
I don't want to squish down into the
shoe. I want pop right off the ground. Um,
and I think like, really
like that is just, I mean,
you've probably experienced this with
the, with the vibrams where like, um,
if you spend the time, your foot feet
gets stronger and stronger and stronger,
and it's only a matter of
time before they get strong.
If you've got to keep kind of working
at it, just like, you know, uh,
a weight lifter, you know, when
they start out weightlifting,
they're nowhere near where they are
10 years later. Um, so like for me,
back in 2012,
I think I kind of like,
you know, I read born to run and
if you've heard of the book, yeah,
I've heard it's amazing. Yeah. You
know, I, I, I read that and I was like,
this is intriguing, you know, and it made
a lot of sense too. It's like, you know,
if we were meant to have
a wedge on our heel,
like we would have had a wedge
on her heel. Yeah, no, that's,
that's a ridiculous thing
that Nike came up with.
And it's really unfortunate that so many
people have adopted that and they've
run, he'll first like that. Yeah. Well in,
in the problem I think too is that like
the shoe is essentially a cast for your
foot.
Even even that vanish that I had up there,
that's a little cast compared to
what you're normally going to see.
But it's still a cast.
That's why I liked those five fingers
cause there's nothing, this is a very,
very flexible rubber rubber underneath
and it's a glove for your, for your feet.
Yeah. Yeah. And you know,
people just know that I think that you
can really work those foot muscles to a
point where you can exhaust them
the way you would in a shoe. Um,
it just takes a lot of time cause like
if I broke my arm and put a cast on it
and then like six,
eight weeks later got the cast taken off,
I went back in the weight
room and did a normal routine,
I would be wrecked the next day.
So when you take your foot
out of that shoe cast,
you have it in or take it out of the
position it's gotten used to and put it in
a different position.
It's like taking a cast off and trying
to do that full mode of mode of a
training or motion. So like, you know, I,
when I first kind of got an ultra running,
I, I, I worked my way
down to a minimal issue.
I spent probably six months before I was
running exclusively and something that
was um, really minimalist.
And when I say minimalist,
I mean zero drop and no cushion
or little to no cushion.
Cause I think some people
confuse that too. Like that the,
the shoe you saw up
there cause she was like,
oh it looks like it's got a
little bit of padding there.
So that's like zero drop with cushioning
or that she really doesn't have a lot
of cushioning. But um, there are
shoes that ultra makes a does.
And what that does is it takes you
from like the way I describe is this is
someone in like a, um, someone
in a traditional running shoe,
real built up cushion. A lot of support
is on one in a spectrum, barefoot runner.
Like those dudes that I
ran into at the track. Um,
they're on the other end of the spectrum.
There's all the steps in
between to get to that. So like,
can't believe people run ultras
barefoot. Yeah. It's crazy.
I don't think there's too many
periods and fucking Saturday,
look at this dude barefoot. Ted. Ted. Ted.
The Sandal.
Yeah.
Sandal. Yeah. Hmm. Well that,
it wasn't that in the born to one that
these guys had made sandals out of tires.
Yeah. Yeah. I've been using
something called a pull up,
this Vivo Vivo Barefoot.
I've been using these. Um,
what I like about these is that I
don't have to look where I step.
There's no cushioning at all.
The trail one, the, I'd use
that one on the far left,
the far left. Yeah. That one.
Um, there's no cushion to it,
but it's got some tread and the bottom
is hard enough so that I could run on
hard rocks and then I
don't think about it.
It's hard to tell in that image
how little there is underneath it.
But there's a,
there's nothing going on in terms of
like there's no squished to it at all to
just some good size knobs.
So you have uh, some good,
some good tread, you know,
so you can, you know,
you can get good traction and dirt and
mud and stuff like that that they weighed
nothing that's global,
that thing up to your foot.
Muscles are flexing every which way.
They were cool.
I made a big difference with me man.
But honestly the five fingers
are probably the best for that.
They just don't have as much traction
and I have to look where I'm stepping,
you know, like I have to be
careful like sharp rocks and stuff.
I have to look down.
Don't step on that one of the guy.
I don't like looking run just
in with those. I can just
run, just flow through it.
Yeah, you can get a faster pace with
those. Yeah. And that's, that's,
that's where I kind of draw the line
too is like when I'm on the roads and on
the track, I don't mind having
that like no cushion type of thing.
But then when I go on like
the trails and Phoenix,
it's very rocky and hard and then I'll
use like a shoe called the king empty.
That's Kinda like the
one that you had there.
It's a little less nimble I would
say. Then that one, but it's got that,
that like really aggressive lug.
It's got the foot shape, toe box,
so I don't feel like my feet
are getting pinch together.
What do you think barefoot Ted
does on the trails? I was trails.
I think he probably wears those
sandals probably, right? Yeah.
Just something where it's got to
something that keeps him from getting cut,
but there are guys who just
do that barefoot to fuck.
I think they're very few,
but it's, it's, it's doable. If you
ever see that show dual survivor,
it's one of those wacky survivor shows.
I don't know if I've seen that one.
This one guy,
I think his name's Corey,
who has the most disgusting fee I've
ever seen in my life almost as discussing
is that one guy was cutting the the
bottom of feet off and feeding it to dog.
The knife videos. Awful. To Watch, but a,
this guy walks barefoot
everywhere and his ideas like,
do you got to toughen your feet up? Cause
you might not have shoes. You know, they,
they get real crazy with
this whole survival is thing.
So this guy is basically has,
I'm not joking,
like a good solid half inch of
callous under his entire foot.
It's amazing what the human body will
do when you put it in a position to need
to. Yeah. And when it has to adapt,
I mean it's one of the reasons why I'm
fascinated by guys like you these ultra
runners is because for the average person,
that's an impossible feat.
But you've built, there's
that guy's foot, look at that.
What ends up fuck it looks like elephant
skin. Yeah. It's fucking gnarly. Um,
but dick guys,
like you have adapted your body
to this position where, you know,
you can do that and it's just a matter
of putting in the training runs and
making sure you're fueling up correctly.
And you know,
a hundred mile race is not a question
whether or not you could do it.
It's how fast he can do it. Yeah.
You know, it's, it's interesting,
the cool thing in this might go back to
what you asked, like why ultra marathons,
and I think it is part of it too, is
like in 100 miles, it's almost like,
it's not a matter of when is
something going to go wrong. It's, um,
or I should say,
if something's gonna go wrong,
it's a matter of when and how
do you respond to it. Right.